>> SO WE'RE BACK AT "SNL," WHICH
IS GREAT.
IT'S MY SIXTH SEASON.
SOMETIMES I STILL FEEL LIKE
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHO I AM.
AT THE END OF LAST YEAR I
THOUGHT MAYBE IT'S FINALLY
HAPPING.
EN THE THIS SUMMER HAPPENED.
>> "SNL" PETE DAVIDSON HAS
CONFIRMED THAT HE AND ARIANA
GRANDE ARE ENGAGED.
>> THIS YEAR'S GOING TO BE LIT.
GET HERE, BROTHER.
>> LOVE YOU, MAN.
>> HEY, LAUREN.
>> HEY, KEVIN.
>> FEEL LIKE THIS YEAR I'VE GOT
TO MAKE A STATEMENT.
SO I'M GOING TO CHANGE THINGS UP
A BIT.
>> OKAY.
YOU SURE YOU WANT TO DO THIS?
>> YEAH.
>> OKAY.
HERE WE GO.
>> WHAT UP?
>> WHY YOU SO LATE, MAN?
>> WHAT DOES IT MATTER, BRO?
I WAS JUST DOING MY THING.
>> BY THE WAY THAT SHIRT'S
ACTUALLY PRETTY LIT.
>> I LOVE THIS, BRO.
PEOPLE ARE FINALLY STARTING TO
TAKE ME SERIOUSLY.
THEN ALL I NEED IS A HOT
CELEBRITY BOYFRIEND AND THAT'S
FINE BY ME.
YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO WRITE ME
INTO YOUR SKETCHES, Y'ALL GOT TO
WRITE MY GIRLFRIEND IN TOO.
YOU KNOW WENDY WILLIAMS.
WE ADOPTED A PIG.
SWAG.
>> YO O, CUTTY, Y HEARD YOU WERE
HANGING OUT.
HOW COME YOU DIDN'T HIT ME BACK?
>> I GUESS I WAS JUST BUSIY.
>> YEAH, BUSY.
>> DON'T YOU KNOW IB HAVE LIKE
MENTAL PROBLEMS?
>> ME TOO.
>> YOU WANT TO COME OUGHT ME?
>> CHILL.
Y'ALL WANT TO SETTLE THIS, DO IT
THE "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE' WAY,
COOL?
>> COOL.
♪
>> GENTLEMAN, CHOOSE WISELY.
>> GUYS, GUYS, GUYS, GUYS, AS
HOST OF THE SHOW I THINK I HAVE
TO ASK YOU NOT TO DO THIS.
>> YOU DON'T BELONG HERE.
>> NOW FIGHT.
♪
>> I'M GOING TO ENJOY THIS.
>> WHY ARE WE DOING THIS, MAN?
I DON'T WANT TO FIGHT YOU.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH, MAN.
WE'RE FRIENDS.
♪
>> HA-HA.
[ LAUGHTER]
>> WELL, IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
FRIENDS AGAIN.
>> AND I GUESS I LEARNED IT
DOESN'T MATTER HOW YOU LOOK OR
HOW POPULAR YOU ARE, IT'S JUST
ABOUT HAVING FUN.
>> YEAH, WHAT'S THAT?
>> DOCTOR SAYS I'M GOING TO DIE
A LITTLE LATER.